zach thompson's been uh terrific 27
years old
he was uh in the white sox organization
for six years
grisham a 261 hitter good speed
11 homers 38 batted in he's 9 out of 11
in stolen bases and leading off for
these padres
here comes the next offering swing and a
miss
thompson got him down and in and he
chased
and grisham is out on strikes to get
this one underway
one down in the first inning for tommy
pham heading out of the two spot for the
friars
jumps on the first pitch and jolts it
out towards right center field that ball
is going to be gone
home run tommy pham with his 11th of the
year gets the padres on top one to
nothing
line drive home run out to right center
field get that man the swag chain
all over the first pitch you got the
four seam fastball and you jump on it
straight sugar hill gang jump on it he
got it
and sent it to the eye yes spin it
machado now third most rbis
in the national league tied with
fernando in fact he's driven in 66 runs
on the season
16 homers 19 doubles couple of triples
for him as well
and the 1-0 pitch hit on the ground
right to the shortstop now get a run
home
rojas has it long throw to first base
plenty of time rbi ground out manny
machado
and two nothing padres in the first
inning will myers will be the batter
here's the 2-2 swinging a miss struck
him out
down on strikes came right back with the
change up
and struck out will myers second
strikeout
ford thompson and uh out number three of
the inning
joe musgrove he's got a no-hitter under
his belt he's five wins seven losses
up and down with the 3.14 era for the
san diego padres
two on one out for aguilar the leading
rbi guy in the national league this
season
three out of six with a couple of home
runs against musgrove for aguilar two of
those home runs came in the same game
one day in pittsburgh one one pitch
reached four and hit on the ground right
to kim at short goes to second one
kronenworth onto first that is as
easy as it gets a 6-4-3 double play
aguilar now tied for the team lead
grounding into seven double plays this
season
and the inning is over no runs two hits
and a man left
after an inning in miami it's the padres
two of the bar looks nothing
grisham for one he struck out to start
the game against thompson
2-2 ground ball up the middle and under
the glove of rojas
muskrobe being waved around here comes
the throw from center from marta it's up
the line and the padres
get their third run so got away
and taking second base is trent grisham
so the padres on top three nothing
and joe mosgrove starting this rally in
the inning
a little two out thunder fam homard
on the first pitch he saw tonight in the
first inning and bats again here in the
second with
grisham at second base by the way for
musgrove who scored the run in this
inning to give them a three to nothing
lead
his third hit of the season here's a one
hopper for miggy
he has it throws to first for the out
so there's that elusive third out of all
the leading home run hitter on the
marlin team he's got 21 on the season
musgrove when he pitched his no-hitter
against texas
back on april 9th didn't walk a batter
in the
no no here's a ball lifted in the air
high and deep to left center
it is going to be up up and away
and a home run for adam duvall number 22
and the marlins are on the board here in
the bottom of the second
it's now a three to one game most of
thompson's time was spent in the white
sox organization so obviously
as an american league team they never
had their pitchers hit in the minors
oh two curveball on the inside corner
strike three call
first of the night for joe as he made
very quick work of the
university of texas at arlington
maverick
zach thompson rojas grounded his
shortstop in the first hope for one
gun ball trickle down the third baseline
machado bare-handed and what a play
other side two for hosmer nice play
manny machado with third base fires to
first hosmer comes up with it
some fancy footwork to get it done
here's jesus aguilar hit into an
inning ending 6-4-3 double play in the
first
marlins had two on with one out aguilar
up and he hit into that twin killing
oh two is
[Applause]
is being held at third aguilar gets to
second in rbi
double aggie comes through with two outs
a one run game and now two runners in
scoring position for duvall who's
already homered
two and two joe set here's the pitch
duval
goes down reaches for it and flares it
into center field grisham is there
he makes the catch and the inning is
over little mini two-out rally against
musco for the marlins they get a run on
a couple of hits
but they leave two men in scoring
position will struck out his first time
over one
one-two curveball for a strike myers is
punched out
and one way in the top of the fourth
inning cindy leone
stands in with one out
strike three second strikeout for
muskrobe
two down in the fourth inning made quick
work of sandy leone
yo rojas has grounded out a short and
grounded out to third
swing and a miss and striking out is
rojas
third strikeout for joe muskrow two down
here in the fifth inning
two down in the fifth for diaz
faces empty two outs oh and two to diaz
pitched for muskrove swung on and missed
strike three
back to back k's as he does work a
second straight one two three inning
we are through five in miami padres
three in the marlins too
sandia is scheduled to bat next year for
the fish
here's the 2-2 to diaz swinging a miss
got him to go after the curve ball
and the inning comes to a close no runs
a hit and the marlins leave two
head to the eighth inning in miami
padres still in front by a run it's
three to two
russia struck out three times in this
game twice swinging once
looking on the ground to first base
coming home as aguilar his throw will
get away
run scores kernelworth is in here comes
machado
he's safe padres get a couple of runs
out of this and myers ends up at second
base
kim is playing as a sit fernando tatis
jr
to third and a great play by diaz
strong throw and they get him esan has
played a really slick third
in the last few weeks he makes the play
for round number three but the padres
get a couple
so wallach will hit the runner on second
two down
3-2 pitch from malanson
he struck him in the padres win mark
melanson will collect his 30th save of
the year
fifth time in his career that he's had
30 saves or more